-Hello, everyone,
and welcome back to the attic.
A lotta you have commented
on the length
of my hair recently
and some of you have gone so far
as to tweet that,
with my hair this long,
I look like a less attractive
Josh Meyers and, to those
people, I just wanna say --
Mom, when did you get
on Twitter?
But, rest assured, as soon
as I can get a haircut, I will.
Or, maybe, just maybe,
I'll let it keep growing
and get a job
as one of Trump's doctors.
And, speaking of Trump's
doctors, they're bad,
because they either gave
the president hydroxychloroquine
or he's lying about taking it
and, honestly,
I'm not sure
which is more psychotic.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
[ Suspenseful theme plays ]
President Trump
is overseeing one
of the worst cataclysms
in American history
and part of reason for that is
he's less focused on prevention
and more focused
on pushing shortcuts
and unproven miracle cures,
which, his own medical advisers
have repeatedly pushed back on.
-Deborah, have you ever heard
of the heat and the light,
relative to certain viruses,
yes, but relative to this virus?
-Not as a treatment.
-You take a solid flu vaccine,
you don't think
that would have an impact
or much of an impact on corona?
-No.
-[ As Trump ]
Okay, but what if you
take a battery --
say, I don't know, a six-volt --
and you cover it
with Pepto-Bismol
and maybe like put it
under your pillow overnight,
would that work?
Okay. Shaking your head no
on that one.
What if, instead of a battery,
it's Sudafed,
and you bury it
in your backyard
and the first person
who finds it is immune?
Is that possible?
Okay.
You know what?
I can't tell if you're
shaking your head no
or shaking your head yes.
It's back and forth.
Which one is it?
You know what?
I think why don't we
just offline this?
Because the modern
conservative movement
is largely a haven for hucksters
and con artists,
it makes sense
that they fell for a guy
who spent his whole career
selling chintzy
and, in many cases,
fraudulent products.
We all know about the steaks,
the water, the wine,
the ties, the magazine,
the Trump Foundation,
the Trump Institute,
the Trump Network,
Trump University,
Trump Mortgage, Trump Dojo,
Trump Airlines,
the vodka, the deodorant.
Yes, we made up Trump Dojo,
but, really, would it
surprise you, if we hadn't?
Can't you just picture him
in a karate uniform
and black belt,
doing his own commercials
in between traffic reports
on the local news?
[ As Trump ]
Come on down to Trump Dojo.
We'll teach you moves like judo;
taekwondo; and my favorite,
jujutsu(e) me for unpaid bills.
I mean, he's always doin'
[ Laughing ]
those weird hand movements
that look like some janky
version of business karate.
[ As Trump ]
I'm blocking your question
and, now, I'm bouncing it.
I'm bouncing it back to you
and that,
that's business hand karate.
And the tapes, the how-to tapes,
can be yours for just $19.99.
Even Trump's presidential
campaign was a crappy,
as-seen-on-TV scam product,
as his lawyer
Michael Cohen explained
in congressional
testimony last year.
-Donald Trump is a man
who ran for office
to make his brand great,
not to make our country great.
He had no desire or intention
to lead this nation,
only to market himself
and to build
his wealth and power.
Mr. Trump would often say,
this campaign was going to be
the greatest infomercial
in political history.
-Of course it was
an infomercial.
That's why his baggy suits
look like Slankets,
he pumps his fists like he's
holding two Shake Weights,
and he sits like
he's using a ThighMaster.
[ As Trump ]
The great thing
about invisible ThighMaster is
it doesn't take up closet space.
And it can be yours
for $19.99.
And Trump doesn't just treat
his own campaign and presidency
like an infomercial.
He also surrounds himself
with other infomercial salesmen,
like the MyPillow guy;
or con artists,
like his former Acting Attorney
General Matthew Whitaker --
remember him? --
who helped run a scam
patent company accused
of bilking investors
out of millions
and once marketed
a so-called masculine toilet
which boasted
a specially designed bowl
to help well-endowed men
avoid unwanted contact
with porcelain or water.
"The average male genitalia
is between five and six inches,"
the firm's press release said,
"however, this invention
is designed
for those of us who measure
longer than that."
So, you went through
all the trouble
of comin' up
with a scam product,
just so you could put out
a press release
makin' it sound
like you got a big [bleep]
Did you even sell any
of these toilets
or did you just put the title
in your Tinder bio?
Also, give me a break.
You're tellin' me
your dong's so big,
every time you squat
down in a toilet,
you're takin' a tip dip
in the tool pool?
And, yeah, I did just come up
with the terms
tip dip and tool pool.
And I'm not sayin'
they should start sellin'
the masculine toilet again,
but, if they did,
they could use both of those
terms in their advertising
for a very reasonable royalty.
Anyway, the point is, Trump
didn't come outta nowhere.
Remember, this is a party
that has elevated
so-called prosperity
gospel preachers;
radio hosts who sell
their audience vitamins
and gold coins;
and TV doctors,
like Dr. Oz and Dr. Phil,
who, for some reason,
always glows like he just took
a bath in a nuclear reactor.
In fact, Trump himself once even
had his own healthcare company,
called the Trump Network,
which asserted that it
could use a urine test
to recommend customized
nutritional supplements.
It also offered products
that purportedly tested
for allergies and bone health,
but scientists said
such claims were never
backed up by modern medicine.
Oh!
Oh, they weren't?
So you're tellin' me,
if I mail my urine
to the guy who told people
they could cure coronavirus
by mixin' themselves
a Clorox cocktail,
he can't really improve
my bone health?
Knowin' Trump, he wanted
your urine for something else.
That's probably why
Trump Vodka tasted like piss.
[ As Trump, laughing ]
Who cares what it tastes like?
It's yours for $19.99.
So, as shocking as it was,
it only made sense
that Trump would publicly
announce to the world,
in the middle of a pandemic
that ravaged the country,
due, in large part,
to his incompetence,
that he was personally taking
a potentially dangerous
antimalaria drug,
to prevent coronavirus,
that he's been hawking,
without proof, for weeks.
-A lotta good things have come
out about the hydroxy.
A lot of good things
have come out.
I happen to be takin' it.
I happen to be
takin' it.
-[ Clamoring ]
-You mean chloroquine?
-I'm takin' it,
hydroxychloroquine.
-When?
-Right now, yeah.
-Yeah, when?
-Couple of weeks ago,
I started takin' it.
-Why, sir.
-'Cause I think it's good.
I've heard a lotta good stories.
-Can you explain, sir, though,
what is the evidence that it
has a preventative effect?
-Here we go.
Are you ready?
Here's my evidence.
I get a lot of positive
calls about it.
-You gotta be careful, man.
People your age
get a lot of scam calls.
It wouldn't surprise me
if we found out the White House
had a reverse mortgage on it.
[ As Trump ]
Don't worry, guys,
Magnum told me
this was above board.
Your evidence is that
you hear good stories
and get positive calls about it.
We're talkin'
about a potentially
dangerous medication,
not the new hibachi
place in town.
[ As Trump ]
I hear good things.
I love the little volcano
they make with the onions,
but be careful.
One time, I leaned
over the grill too far.
That's why I look like this.
Also don't say "Are you ready?"
Like you're about to blow
everyone's mind
and then follow it up
with "I hear good stories."
He's like a skateboarder
who tells his bros
to "Film this"
and then immediately lands
nards-first on a handrail.
"Oh, bro, I'm postin'
this right now. #tipdip"
Look, now that the term exists,
we're gonna use it.
I'm really havin' a hard time
wrappin' my head around this
and how psychotic it is.
I mean, look, Trump's gonna say
and do crazy [bleep]
He failed
in the pandemic response
and unemployment is at its
highest point in 100 years,
so, now, he's sprayin'
ink in the water
so he can dart under a rock
before the press
can figure out what happened.
We don't have to spend
all day dissecting it,
debating whether it's a chess
move or a planned distraction.
The guy doesn't play chess.
He doesn't even know how
to close an umbrella.
Watching him play chess
would be like asking your dog
to change the channel
on the remote control.
"Hey, man,
you watchin' the game?"
No, Animal Planet again.
But what is important is that
Trump, as the president,
actually influences
other people.
Like the time he mused
about disinfectants
curing the virus
and people actually called
their state
and local governments
to ask if it was okay
to chug bleach.
-We had hundreds of calls come
into our emergency hotline
at our health department,
asking if it was right
to ingest Clorox
or, you know,
alcohol cleaning products,
whether that was gonna
help them fight the virus.
So, we had to put out
that warning to make sure
that people were not
doing something like that,
which would kill people,
actually, to do it.
-The government actually had
to tell people,
"Don't listen to the president.
Ingesting bleach is bad."
But I do like that people were
considering drinking bleach,
but also, responsible enough
to call and check first.
Uh-huh.
Uh-huh. Oh.
So, it burns?
Oof!
Really?
That much?
[ Southern accent ]
Well, good thing I called
[ Laughing ]
and you have a nice day, too.
This is a medication
that can have
potentially deadly side effects.
A small chloroquine study
in Brazil was halted
over the risk of fatal
heart complications in patients;
a French study found
that hydroxychloroquine
doesn't help patients
with coronavirus;
and a study found
that the drug was linked
to higher rates of death
in coronavirus patients
and the side effects can
potentially include agitation,
insomnia, confusion, mania,
hallucinations, paranoia,
as well as lasting psychiatric
and neurological symptoms.
So, either Trump's lyin'
about taking it
or he's been takin' it
for 73 years?
"Our baby's pretty colicky."
Just give him a little
hydroxychloroquine
on his gums
for the rest of his life.
So, that's on top of the
hallucinations he already has.
Is there a possible
reverse effect,
where the hallucinations
and paranoia
cancel each other out
and makes him normal?
Is he gonna show up
to his next press conference
in a plaid shirt and khakis?
[ As Trump ]
Hello, everyone.
My name's John
and I just wanna say the press
is an invaluable part
of our democracy.
Now, if you'll excuse me,
I wanna go drink some water
by bringing the glass up
to my face
with one hand,
like a normal person.
In fact,
judging from this comment
about the made-up scandal
he calls Obamagate,
it sounds like Trump
might already be feeling
some side effects.
-Obama knew everything
that was happening.
I don't think Obama knows
where he, uh,
you know, is, in a lotta ways.
I saw his statements
the other day
and I think that, frankly,
they weren't very good.
That's President Obama.
-Damn, are you swallowing
the hydroxychloroquine,
or snortin' it?
[ As Trump ]
Come on, man!
Let me get my drox on!
Daddy's gotta ride the quine.
[ Snorting ]
Hail, Hydra!
And then, there's the fact
that Trump's relentless
hawking of this product
has created shortages
for people who need it.
It's a life-saving drug,
for people
with conditions like Lupus,
and they were already struggling
to get hydroxychloroquine,
due, in part,
to the president hyping it up
as a coronavirus treatment.
Lupus patients reported
having to ration their pills
because of the
hydroxychloroquine shortage,
with one telling USA Today,
"When I have that medicine,
I can live life normally
and don't have
to think about it.
Now, I have to stop and think
before I even pick up my
toothbrush to brush my teeth,"
and that's horrifying because,
if people get distracted
before brushing,
you'll have to deal
with a second ailment,
known as Rudy's Teeth.
Rudy, ugh!
My God, man, I've never
said this to anyone, but,
maybe have your teeth removed?
You might look better
with just gums.
Seriously, how are
your top teeth
and bottom teeth so different?
Could you only afford half
a box of Crest Whitestrips?
Most public health experts
have cautioned
against the president's
reckless touting
of hydroxychloroquine,
like ousted vaccine
Chief Rick Bright,
who testified last week
that he was punished, in part,
for questioning Trump's
advertising of the drug.
-I believe part of the removal
process for me was initiated
because of a pushback
that I gave
when they asked me
to put in place
an expanded access protocol
that would make chloroquine
more freely available
to Americans
that were not under the close
supervision of a physician
and may not even be confirmed
to be infected
with the coronavirus.
-They wanted to give it
to people
who do not even have
coronavirus.
You know, when I heard that,
I never thought that last group
would include the president
of the United States.
"They asked me
to make chloroquine
freely available to Americans
that were not under the close
supervision of a doctor,
may not be infected
with coronavirus,
and whose symptoms include
sitting on the edge
of their seat
like they're trying
to not to take a, um..."
"...a, um,
tip dip in the tool pool."
But the hype got started
with a small French study
of just 20 patients,
which medical experts
have since called pathetic
and a complete failure
and which the publisher
itself has said
didn't meet its standards.
The study was co-authored
by an eccentric French doctor
named Didier Raoult.
And, before I show you
his photo,
here is a photo
of Trump's former doctor
Harold Bornstein.
Remember him?
Now, I want you to imagine
what Didier Raoult looks like.
Are you ready?
Okay.
Here he is!
[ Laughing ]
Mon dieu!
He's Harold Bornstein's
French cousin.
[ stoner voice ]
Hey, Didi, wanna come over
to the States, man?
I got backstage passes
to the Steely Dan concert.
[ French accent ]
Hello, American cousin.
I wish I could, but I am busy
attaching electrodes
to a baguette,
to see if it will talk.
Seriously, why do all
of Trump's favorite doctors
look like they found
their medical degree
in a Porta Potti at Woodstock?
They look like they went
into quarantine
during the swine flu
and just never came out.
[ stoner voice ]
Hey, man, I think --
Hey, I think it's safe, man.
Didier!
I think it's safe.
And, just to give you an idea
of how psychotic
Trump's comment was,
doctors and TV anchors
had to urge viewers not
to follow his lead.
Even Fox News urged caution.
-If you are in a risky
population, here,
and you are taking this
as a preventative treatment
to ward off the virus
or, in a worst-case scenario,
you are dealing with the virus
and you are in this
vulnerable population,
it will kill you.
I cannot stress enough --
this will kill you.
It sounds like
what you're saying,
you have a risk
of losing your life,
if you do what the president
just recommended.
-That's correct.
Be very, very careful
of what you put in your mouth
and what you swallow,
be it liquid or solid.
-That's right,
thanks to the president,
a doctor literally had to go
on TV and tell people,
"Be careful what you put
in your mouth
and what you swallow,"
like he was talkin'
to children playing
with Matchbox cars.
Donald, where's that toy car
you were just playing with?
[ As Trump ]
Uh, it went through a tunnel.
Of course, Fox News
has been loyally parroting
Trump's hydroxychloroquine
talking points for weeks, now,
and the surprising show
of dissent from Cavuto
prompted a characteristically
pissy tweet
from Trump last night.
".@FoxNews
is no longer the same.
We miss the great Roger Ailes.
You have more anti-Trump people,
by far, than ever before.
Looking for a new outlet!"
Ah, yes, the great Roger Ailes,
the famous creep
who oversaw a culture
of paranoia
and sexual harassment
at Fox News
that led to him getting fired
by liberal snowflake --
let me see --
Rupert Murdoch.
The conservative movement
elevated a huckster
who spent his career
pushing scam products
and miracle cures
to the presidency
and, now, he's doing the same
thing with a pandemic
that has ravaged the country
and cratered the economy.
Next time people think
about voting for Trump,
the media might want to warn
them there's a chance...
-It will kill you.
-This has been
"A Closer Look."
♪♪
During the COVID crisis,
City Harvest
has been stepping up
to rescue and deliver more food
to meet the increased need
in New York City.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe. Wash your hands.
We love you.